today we're going to be speaking with
thomas homer dixon who's the executive
director of the cascade institute at
royal roads university in british
columbia canada his new book is
commanding hope the power we have to
renew a world in peril
some of you may may recognize his name
because he was also the author of an
article we spoke about in january called
the american polity is cracked and might
collapse canada must prepare it's really
great to have you on today i appreciate
your time
delighted to be with you david so your
article was essentially written as a
cautionary
message to canada about you know us uh
the the traditionally democratic
neighbor to the south and the
possibility that by 2030 the u.s could
become uh to use your term a right-wing
dictatorship um can can we start by
talking about
uh
that that's only eight years a
relatively short amount of time
what would be the path for the u.s to
become that over the next eight years
in the article i
postulate that donald trump is
re-elected in 2024
and that is really the critical stage in
the process that
could see the devolution of american
democracy into
an authoritarian regime of some kind
and people have been beating around in
the in the bushes about this using
various terms autocracy authoritarian
regime but i just say look
if we're going to have one person
putting himself above the rule of law in
the united states then then that is a
dictatorship and we should just call it
a dictatorship so the critical stage
would be donald trump's reelection
i don't know whether he would actually
consolidate
the
a right-wing dictatorship in the united
states it might take a period of time it
might be one of his successors
but i think he would put democracy in
the united states in extreme jeopardy i
don't think there's any doubt about that
he would return to office with the goals
of vindication and vengeance really and
he would be unleashed given that it
would probably be his last term in
office
and uh
i think that
creates enormous concern around the
world not just within the united states
yes so this was a warning to canadian
citizens to start preparing for this
possibility
the the word dictatorship can mean in
practice many different things and
sometimes there's associations with uh
police states um uh you know just
willy-nilly imprisonment of media or
political dissidents uh people as you
know we sometimes say jokingly although
it's not a joke accidentally stabbing
themselves ten times when they happen to
you know this type of thing
which of these characteristics do you
think would be plausible in such an
american circumstance
that's a very good question i lay out a
number of pathways
in the article uh the most benign i
would be i would say is something
resembling and this wouldn't really
qualify as a dictatorship of course
would something resembling victor
orban's
illiberal democracy in hungary yes but i
think we could go all the way through to
something closer to what we see in
russia right now under vladimir putin
that seems extreme and seems
implausible i think for many people
especially on the liberal end of the
spectrum but some of the rhetoric that
you're hearing now on the right
against media for instance
lock them up shoot them
uh even from people who are are
increasingly
accepted as part of the mainstream
discourse in the united states
it's rhetoric that you would expect from
uh
of people who want to impose that kind
of uh brutality within the american
polity
so one of the points i make within the
article is that
uh
a a critical development here is the
propagation of what scholars call a
hardline security doctrine in the united
states
uh and it's been associated with some of
the most brutal regimes they've
transitioned from democracy and i use
the example of weimar germany in the
1920s and 30s that the transition from
democracy to a dictatorship
and a critical element of that process
has been the propagation of a hardline
security doctrine which suggests for
people who adhere to it that there are
uh individuals within the society and
groups within the society embedded
across the society within civilian
sectors of the society that are
enemies of the state
who are
and enemies of the nation more generally
and who have to be
identified and ostracized or even
eliminated and that kind of rhetoric is
now becoming much more common on the
right in the united states and that's a
precursor of uh of not just not just
a soft authoritarian regime but it's the
kind of thing you would see as a
precursor for a much more brutal regime
in the um in the aftermath of the 2020
election which donald trump who lost
claimed that he won
uh we were i mean
whether we were surprised is it is a
question but many of us were certainly
distraught that more than half of the
republican party believed it they they
at least said that they believed that
joe biden did not really win that
election can you talk a little bit about
in this potential dictatorial slide
how important
does it matter whether a significant
portion of the population buys the lies
of the would-be dictator oh it matters
enormously i mean it's the one of the
critical elements here that is a poison
and again it's quite similar to
that that false falsehood
the big lie is quite similar to the
falsehood that
the nazis used to uh to
reinforce their own legitimacy the stab
in the back the the idea again listen to
the sort of the rhetoric of the
hard-line security doctrine the idea
that there was a group in this
particular
principally uh jews within within
germany who had conspired against
germany during the second world war
during the first world war at the end of
the first world war and it stabbed
germany in the back and it defeated
germany from within
and and uh
so the the lie that's being propagated
now the falsehood
that um the election was stolen from
donald trump
enough
and widely believed and accepted
by supposedly somewhere around 70
percent of republicans now yeah
uh so what are we looking at 30 of the
american
electorate 25 to 30 percent of the
american electorate
uh it
you you you can seize power within a
society
with a mobilized and coordinated
fraction of the society that large 20 to
30 percent absolutely 100 percent if if
everybody else is squabbling and
disorganized and not realizing what the
nature of the danger is
and not reinforcing the the institutions
of democracy
it it's certainly large enough to
uh impose
a an institutional transition on the
society away from democracy
so yes that that
that falsehood and the fact that it's
widely believed and a substantial
proportion of of republicans also
believe that violence is justified in
returning
trump to the presidency or would be
justified
uh is as i say within the article it's
poison within the body politic of the
united states and it's coursing through
the entire body politic now you
mentioned um
world war ii and pre-world war ii era
germany
there's been i mean for decades at this
point you hear some on the american
right and maybe elsewhere say
if the jews had had guns
the holocaust wouldn't have happened
historians have looked at this it's been
widely
debunked and explained away
i
i am curious about
what you imagine i mean gun culture in
the united states is very different than
than in canada and um i'm curious what
you imagine
the potential role of civilian owned
guns to be in an authoritarian takeover
of the us and this is with the specific
reality that
it's definitely
more of the folks
who believe the big lie that would be
likely to have the guns and this is why
among many of my liberal friends many
many are now saying
i'm not a big gun person but i don't
want them to be the only ones with the
guns give us a sense whether you know
you have some thoughts as to the role of
civilian-owned guns in such a world
you know it's enormously important uh
so
in a sense and you're being very gentle
in your description of this situation by
the way
in a sense what we have is a development
of an arms race and i and a a weapons
race between different ideological camps
and this highly polarized society and
then a disintegration of what social
scientists call social capital which is
the trust the bonds of trust and
reciprocity the help bind societies
together societies with high social
capital tend to prosper solve their
problems effectively and those without
don't and we're seeing that it's a it's
a terrible degenerative process and i
think guns are
a really important element of that
because they induce a lot of fear
just as you were describing and the fear
causes the retreat to what what um
political scientists call a kind of
self-help situation where you feel you
have to take care of yourself and we all
feel that
and um now the irony is that the second
amendment and the gun culture in the
united states is ideologically justified
uh on the right by the fear of a tyrant
right that that we need to we need to
maintain our capacity to rebel against
an authoritarian state because that's
part of the
it's almost the civic religion of the
united states going back to the
revolution and and justifiably in in a
lot of ways of course the second
amendment is completely wildly
misinterpreted from its original intent
um
uh but uh yes i would say that the folks
who
tend to support
an authoritarian shift or would support
an authoritarian shift in the united
states who are not supportive of
democracy as it currently exists in the
united states uh will tend to have a
disproportionate
uh a
number of these weapons 400 million
currently i think in the civilian
population in the united states is just
breathtaking now what would happen at
you have all these heavily armed people
around
and you have a
the implementation of a
authoritarian regime which would have
elements of a plutocracy probably
because it would um be supported by
wealthy certain elements of wealthy
elites in the united states
uh
what's going to happen to all these
folks who are heavily armed who suddenly
find that they actually really are
living within a
a dictatorship and that's an interesting
question you might actually find that
there's a great deal of opposition from
folks who might have otherwise supported
or originally supported the shift in the
institutions
at this point where it's complete
speculation we have really no idea where
things could go
but it's
again uh what i was doing in my article
was just opening up these questions
because in canada we at least need to
start considering them and talking about
them what do you think the role has been
from seeing
um
what's happening in russia for example
or um in in other countries around the
world where i mean really it's it's
these sort of authoritarians that donald
trump sometimes played coy with and
sometimes even expressed admiration for
what what sort of effect do you think
that has had on the population in the
united states
so this is a really interesting question
and development and somewhat unexpected
i mean i i've been watching putin's
build-up of arms since since last year
and i actually felt that it was quite
likely he was going to attack ukraine
but i hadn't expected first of all what
we've seen is a democratic rallying
around the world the rallying of
democratic countries to come together in
in in the defense of ukraine
uh and all of the folks like victor
orban and jared bolsnaro and
marie le pen in france all of the folks
who had cozied up to putin in various
ways
heading for the exits because all of a
sudden they've been substantially
delegitimized i mean
this is a real world lesson and what
happens when you get a dictatorship
dictatorships tend to go to war
democracies don't go to war with each
other it's one of the strongest
empirical laws or generalizations in the
social sciences that's called the
democratic peace hypothesis
if you end up with something like putin
or
an authoritarian regime you're much more
likely to go to war because what happens
with these folks and this is part of
what's happening in russia is as their
legitimacy declines internally because
authoritarian regimes tend not to solve
their problems very well they have
economic crises and things as their
legitimacy and popularity declines
internally they pick
fights with their enemies or with
external enemies
and uh to try to build up the leaders
try to build up their authority and
popularity internally by picking fights
externally so
so we're getting a very vivid lesson
in the kind of world we will be creating
if we give up on democracy and i think
in an extraordinary way this is a silver
lining from this this war i mean it's a
terrible terrible situation but it's
sort of reminded everyone in the world
what's at stake
and i think i think it actually puts
donald trump in an interesting way and
something of a
vulnerable position in the united states
as we come into for instance the
midterms and the in the presidential
election campaign that'll be very
interesting to see uh in terms of what
what impact it has for sure uh we're
going to link to thomas homer dixon's
article that's been the jumping up
jumping off point for our conversation
today the new book is commanding hope
the power we have to renew a world in
peril i so appreciate your time today
thank you so much
thank you